Hi everyone,
my name is M. Drinko.
I'm a dairy farmer
and I also do at the Drinko Dairy on TikTok.
I just like to take 2 minutes to talk to you
about mental health and farming.
Agriculture has one of the highest rates of suicide
in the UK. It is the biggest killer of farmers,
which is absolutely heartbreaking and needs to change.
The next time you're at the pub with your mates
and someone asks
are you okay?
It is perfectly fine to say,
you know what?
No, I'm not feeling 100% today.
Because it's okay not to be. Okay.
We need to do something about this.
And the way to do that
is bring about new thinking of this.
So let's do just that and let's get talking.